we've already made several videos over
evolution and just remind ourselves what
evolution is talking about the change in
heritable traits of a population over
generations and a lot of times you'll
hear people say evolution and natural
selection really in the same breath but
what we want to make a little bit
clearer in this video is that natural
selection is one mechanism of evolution
and it's the one most talked about
because it is viewed as the primary
mechanism natural selection but we're
going to talk about in this video is
another mechanism called genetic drift
so there's natural selection and there
is genetic genetic drift now we've done
many videos on natural selection but
it's this idea that you have variation
in a population you have different
heritable traits I'm going to depict
those with different colors here we have
a population of living circles here and
they could come in blue or maybe magenta
maybe they come in another variation -
maybe there's maybe there is yellow
circles and natural selection is all
about which of these traits are most fit
for the environment so that they can
reproduce so there might be something
about being say blue that allows those
circles to reproduce faster or to be
less likely to be caught by predators or
to be able to stalk prey better and so
they are even they're only slightly more
likely to reproduce over time over many
generations their numbers will their
numbers will increase and dominate and
the other numbers are more are less
likely are less likely to or the other
trait is less likely to survive and so
we will have this natural selection for
that blue trait so this is all about
traits being the fittest traits
now genetic drift is also change in
heritable traits of a population over
generations but it's not about the
traits that are most fit for an
environment are the ones that
necessarily survive genetic drift is
really a
out random random random changes random
changes and a good example of that
I have right over here that we got from
I'll give proper credit this is the this
is from openstax college biology and
this shows how genetic drift could
happen so right over here I'm showing a
very small population of we have a
population of 10 rabbits and we have the
gene for four-color and we have two
versions of that gene or we could call
them two alleles you have the capital B
version and you have the lowercase B and
capital B is dominant this is we're just
kind of a very Mendelian example that
we're showing here and so if you have
two lowercase if you have two of the
lowercase genes two of the white alleles
you're going to be white if you have two
of the brown alleles the capital B's
you're going to be brown and if you're a
heterozygote you're still going to be
brown so as you can you can see here
there are several heterozygotes in this
fairly small population but if you just
count the capital B's versus the
lowercase PS you see that we have an
equal amount of each and so the
frequency if you were to pick a random
allele from this population you're just
as likely to pick a capital B then a
lowercase B even though the phenotype
you see a lot more Brown but these these
six brown here have both the uppercase B
and lowercase B now let's say they're in
a population where they where whether
you're brown or whether you are white it
confers no advantage there's no more
likelihood of surviving and reproducing
if you're brown than white but just by
chance by pure random chance the the
five bunnies on the top are the ones
that are able to reproduce and the five
bunnies on the bottom are not the ones
that are able to reproduce and you might
be saying why why did I pick those top
five I didn't pick them I'm just giving
an example it could have been the bottom
five it could have been only these two
or the only two white ones were the ones
that were able to reproduce it's by pure
random chance or it could be because of
traits that are unrelated to
the alleles that we are talking about
but from the point of view of these
alleles it looks like random chance and
so in the next generation in the next
generation those five rabbits reproduce
and you could have a situation like this
and just by random chance as you can see
the capital B allele frequency has
increased from 50% of the alleles in the
population to 70% and then it could be
another random chance and I'm saying
this is necessarily going to happen it
could happen the other way it could
happen even though that that first that
first randomness happened maybe now
sudden this white rabbit is able to
reproduce a lot but maybe not maybe two
of maybe these two brown rabbits that
are homozygous for the dominant trait
are able to reproduce and once again has
nothing to do with Fitness and so
they're able to reproduce and all of a
sudden the white allele has been is
completely gone from the environment and
the reason why this happened isn't
because the white allele is somehow
makes the bunnies less fit in fact it
might have even conferred a little bit
of an advantage it might have been a
permanent from the environment that the
bunnies are in point of view it might
have been a better trait but because of
random chance it it disappears from the
population and the general idea with the
genetic drift so once again just to
compare natural selection you're
selecting trait or the environment is
selecting traits that are more favorable
for reproduction
while genetic drift is random changes
random changes in reproduction of the
population now as you can imagine I just
gave an example with ten bunnies and
what I just described is much more
likely to happen with small populations
so much more likely more likely with
with small populations if if I and we
have videos on statistics on Khan
Academy but the likelihood of this
happening with ten bunnies versus the
likelihood of what we had just described
happening with 10 million bunnies is
very different it's much more likely to
happen with a small population so a lot
of the contexts of genetic drift or when
people talk about small populations in
fact many times mile just are worried
about small populations specifically
because of
a drift for random reasons you could
have less diversity less variation in
your population and even favorable
treats favorable traits could be
selected for by random by random chance
now there's particular there's two tip
there's two types of genetic drift that
are often called out that cause extreme
reductions in population and
significantly reduce the populations one
is called the bottleneck effect let me
write this down so the bottle bottle
neck the bottleneck effect and then the
other is called the founder effect do
that over here the founder founder
effect and they are both they are both
ideas where you have significant
reduction in population for slightly
different reasons bottleneck the effect
is you have some major disaster or event
that kills off a lot of the population
so only a little bit of the population
is able to survive and the reason why
it's called bottleneck because imagine
if you had a bottle here if you had a
bottle here and I don't know inside of
that bottle you had marbles of different
colors so you have some yellow marbles
you have some magenta marbles you have
some I don't know blue marbles these are
the colors that I tend to be using he
has some blue marbles so you have a lot
of variation in your original population
but if you think about pouring them out
of a bottle maybe maybe somehow there's
some major disaster and only two of
these survive or let's say only four of
these survive and so you could view that
is well what are the marbles that are
getting poured out of the bottle it's
kind of just it's really just a metaphor
obviously we're not putting populations
of things in bottles but after that
disaster only a handful survive and they
they might not have any traits that are
any way more desirable or more fit for
the environment than everything else but
they just by random chance because of
this disaster they are the ones that
survived and so all of a sudden you have
a massive reduction not only the
population but also in the very in the
variation in that population and many
deels might have even disappeared and so
you have you have an extreme form of
genetic drift actually occurring
another example is founder effect is
founder effect which is the same idea of
a population becoming very small but the
founder effect isn't because of a
natural disaster it's let's say you had
a population once again you have a lot
of different alleles in that population
you have a lot of variation you have a
lot of variation in that population so
let me just keep coloring it you have a
lot of variation in this population and
let's say that you know they're all
hanging out and in in their region and
maybe you know they are they are
surrounded by they're surrounded by
mountains and I'm just making this up as
I go but let's say a couple of these
blue characters we're out walking one
day and they maybe get separated from
the rest of their population maybe they
discover a little undiscovered mountain
pass and they go settle a new population
someplace so that's why it's called the
founder of fact these are the founders
of a new population and once again by
random chance they just have a lot less
variation they're a smaller population
and they have they happen to be
disproportionately or all blue in this
case and so now this population is going
to one a few you might have already had
this is just the process of this with
genetic drift where you have so many
alleles will have disappeared because
you have such a small population of
blues here and also because you have a
small population you're likely to have
even more genetic drift so it's a really
interesting thing to think about
evolution and natural selection are
often talked about hand-in-hand but
natural selection isn't the only
mechanism of evolution
you also have genetic drift which is
really about not selecting for favorable
traits
it is about randomness